et soudain elle pète bonjour je suis
lucie romaine c'est ici que j'écris mes
sketchs pour gold à moustache
il paraît que vous avez des questions
pour nous première question à quel
personnage que vous avez joué vous
identifier à quel personnage que vous
avez joué vous identifiez vous le plus
dans le sketch la pluie le personnage de
la jeune fille
elle cherchait un chevreuil et moi aussi
c'est la femme de ma vie je le sais je
le ressens mais je n'ai pas besoin de
courir vraiment d'après ton destin comme
un cheval sauvage ça serait pas un
personnage que j'ai joué ça sera un
personnage que j'ai écrit et ça serait
les a dans les dissocier c'est ce que
j'aime beaucoup ce personnage j'aime
beaucoup ce qu'on a fait le lot et voilà
je viens ce qu'ils véhiculent
non françois lecot recours empreinte
c'est pas ton corps c'est surtout pour
ça que ceux qui vont emprunter demain
ouais d'autant plus qu'il est pas toi je
suis la loisne toujours un corps dans le
même état contre la dame est sûrement
maxime d'antibes le disent parce que en
fait le personnage répond exactement ce
que moi je répondrai dans la vie je
pense à peu près y compris va te faire
cuire le cul tu dit de la merde je pense
de la merde t'es de la mer puis ça va
pas nous traiter comme ça je traite
comme je veux une [__] sabine aba
ont été choqués et pourtant je suis
français je suis blanc je suis triés sur
le volet et ben je te le dit une
[__] voilà donc tu vas te faire
cuire le cul avec les idées de merde je
me barre hakim on se marie demain à
17h53 ça te va
nickel dit qu'elle n'y a pas de lieu
c'est juste ce qu'il faut si vous
pouviez être un super héros lequel est
pourquoi je pense hulk parce que hulk je
pense qu'au début les gens savent pas
que c'est hulk ils le font chier
le mec qui devient hulk une fois et
après les gens ils le laissent
tranquille toute sa vie quoi parce
qu'ils ont vraiment pas envie de
l'énerver et donc je pense que bruce
banner c'est le mec le plus au calme du
monde pourquoi hakim est le seul arabe
merde personne personne le fait chier si
tu genre tu dit attends je peux prendre
la dernière par le mec banon j'avais
prévu de la manger moi fait ben vas-y
mon cela pose problème parce que le mec
en cellule quel a été votre parcours
avant d'entrer angolaise moustache bas
tout simple je prends la ligne 8 jusqu'à
ray métier je descends et après je vais
appeler jusqu'au trévise
moi je la trouvais bien j'ai fait des
écoles d'acteur dans paris et après j'ai
fait un peu de stand-up de la scène et
voilà j'ai cru dans un blog où je
faisais un peu de blagues blog excellent
blog et blagues
j'étais dessinateur pendant dessinateurs
et auteurs de bande dessinée pendant 6 7
ans et après j'ai commencé à faire des
vagues
et il ya quelqu'un qui a dit ah il est
marrant et du coup on m'a proposé des
trotteurs aggelen moustache et après je
suis jamais repartie parce que j'étais
bien eh ben j'ai fait du stand up avant
et je suis monté sur scène j'étais
marrant on m'a dit tu voudrais pas
écrire des vidéos
j'ai écrit des vidéos et les vidéos en
plus on m'a dit tu voudrais pas rentrer
chez eux des moustaches et voilà j'ai
commencé chez golden stage je jouais
dans des sketches particulièrement les
sketchs des suricates dont raphaël les
cracks avec qui je jouais dans le
visiteur du futur donc raflé les cracks
et le lien professionnel en tout cas
j'ai fait un bts audiovisuel
j'ai fait une licence cinéma mais j'ai
plus l'impression d'avoir appris par moi
même en faisant des vidéos en fait eh
bien j'ai été au cours florent ensuite
j'ai joué sur scène ensuite je suis
entré à la comédie française où j'ai été
assistant metteur en scène puis metteur
en scène pendant huit ans puis j'ai
participé aux vidéos du palmashow j'en
ai fait 274 avant que flaubert m'appelle
pour entrer chez col d'agnes sache
quelles qualités faut-il pour travailler
dans un collectif comme celui ci
alors il faut être bien sûr drôle il
faut être travailleur et après ce qui
est important c'est faut savoir super
bien joué moi c'est clair qu'en termes
de style de jeu je me situerais plutôt
entre depardieu et r2d2 il faut s'aimer
les uns les autres
moi je peux vous faire plein de trucs
par exemple je peux faire la tristesse
il faut être déterminé
il faut être passionné la joie il faut
accepter que des fois ça ne va pas aussi
vite qu'on voudrait ou aussi bien et
attention ça c'est très chaud la
mansuétude
pourquoi golden moustache pour qu'on
nous pose cette question pour toujours
pour l'éternité de l'univers pour que le
cosmos entier se pose y at il déjà eu
des relations sexuelles consenties au
sein de l'équipe golden moustache mais
pas moi et je ne dirais pas qui c'est
tremblay derrière oui pourquoi tu pressé
ceux consentis en fait parce que c'est
bizarre de de ressentir le besoin de
préciser qu' entre vous et célibataire
et qui est en couple répond non non
répond aux répond la vérité non réponse
qu'on veut moi j'en coup
vous n'avez pas eu de mal à tourner la
scène où vous embrasser dans les
dissocier la première fois que j'ai vu
j'ai tourné avec raphaël des cracks
on s'est masturbé face à face en hurlant
sous un pont donc du coup s'embrasser
après ça c'est pas qu'il est il prévu de
faire un film avec toute la team gold
moustache bah oui j'ai vu les dissocier
gagnon pourquoi quand on fait caca ont
fait pipi en même temps et pas l inverse
si l'inversé possible justin petit pour
content de sex-appeal
je ne comprends pas 10 nitoo secret
pourquoi tant de sex-appeal je ne
comprends pas dit nous tenons moi non
plus je ne sais pas ça bouge pas mal
j'ai voulu faire une faq dans un endroit
insolite donc j'ai fait dans les grandes
routes et ses optiques laverty et
l'envers et plusieurs toits qui dans si
bien pourrais-tu nous apprendre une
petite choré bien sûr
voilà c'est la faq gold al-moussa
j'espère que ça vous a plu à bientôt
salut c'est lucien men j'espère que
cette vidéo vous a plu n'hésitez pas à
vous abonner et soyez également informé
de l'existence du lab tous les vendredis
à 18 heures sur notre site non non mais
pas trop le soir ok les gars genou sur
le fait que les principes